I'm Augustine I'm 18 years old and I've
been cooking for seven years I'm Chester
I'm older than you think I am
and I've been cooking for three years so
today I'm cooking a lamb burger with the
goat cheese middle caramelized onions
with fig butter and bacon I found this
from the internet I put my own twist to
it it's the best burgers I've ever had
today I'm gonna be making a deep-fried
burger of sorts the recipe originated in
Memphis Tennessee and so when I saw this
I knew I had to try it and I thought
this would be the best way to do that I
think his burger might be boring so like
I like stuff on my burger I like bacon I
like goat cheese I just like stuff I
like to eat liked it a lot I don't think
you're better than good I don't want it
to be good I don't think it will be I am
NOT freaking out there's a line there's
a line there what are you gonna use a
line for I like lime chili it reminds me
of margaritas in the event that we don't
agree which burgers better we're joined
by tasty producer Matthew Frances hello
hi guys
I'm excited to see what you guys gonna
cook up for me I see some interesting
ingredients here we're gonna have two
very different burgers
good luck I'll leave you to it I have
this constant fear of like slicing my
fingers open I'm starting here with
getting my cast-iron nice and warm this
can be as hot as it can be because it's
all happening very fast because it's a
very thin cut of meat I'm gonna put some
meat on before I put my actual patties
down because it's important to get the
skillet very greasy because it helps to
cook the patties in the juices so much
it's such a beautiful vegetable right
now I'm just caramelizing onions so I
put butter in there and onions and you
just kind of like cook it on medium
until it gets soft I don't necessarily
understand what the caramelizing process
is I just know they're supposed to taste
good so now I'm gonna work on making my
first patties since you're going to be
crushing them you need to get a fair bit
of meat more than you probably think you
need and ball it up and then as far as
seasoning goes I don't think you ever
need to season your burgers with more
than pepper and salt grab a little bit
of pepper
put that on there well what happened not
that much but all I can do is just do
this got some salt but then I'm both
patties grab a giant hunk of wood and
just smash it move it around so it stays
even and you can see that the salt and
the pepper spread around pretty evenly
in there and then what I'm gonna do is
take it that was some good spatula
action I thank you so much I practice a
lot I had a garlic cilantro and mint to
the lamb just to season it it's such a
strong flavor also that's what the
internet told me to do the onions are
starting to caramelize and I'm adding
fig butter because I saw it in a
different recipe and I was like cool
let's combine these recipes together and
make a super recipe what I'm gonna have
to do pretty soon is prepare the buns I
take some mustard and I spray it on
there
and then you want to grab your pickles I
love pickles I like to put more pickles
in there I will it's not for you though
there's a documentary on Netflix called
acid fat and salt and so this is acid
interestingly enough acid has a lot to
do with my burger when you use pickles
and onion it balances out the acidity of
using grease as a condiment you know a
lot of stuff for a Jen's ear do you know
what a floppy disk is no I have
completed my second burger here this is
a good example of why fewer ingredients
are better it's a form of Arts and
Crafts what goes in there you can't give
the surprise away you have to hide a
little bit behind me do you need my
burner it's mine yeah it's going to my
hands a granny key that's big
you did it to get it all off if you
don't put it there
the edge there you go she's got it I got
it smells like a walk around all right a
locker room
smells like a locker locker with cheese
and lamb together you know what okay
I noticed you're not doing anything
right now she has commandeered my burner
she has okay kind of spreading out yeah
okay I'm doing the man spread yeah love
it love it and I am done with 200k how
you're gonna keep it warm that is a
problem I think I'll just throw it on
and make another one when she's doing
okay that will say I appreciate a warm
hot burger though yeah we were toasted
buns before I have toasted buns before
it was really fun but I didn't see a
toaster around in do it nerd yeah fine I
see I like a toasted bun me too
that's a good tip I'll do that for my
final burger okay he said it's a lot
like a locker room
I don't like this movie I thought that's
key for me there's a lot going on here I
say you guys keep cooking do your best
and make sure you really impress me come
I'm hungry oh yeah that actually looks
kind of good yeah yeah I'll take that
no thank you I just like different
colors in their burgers I know you
design your burger by how it looks
I'm more interested in how food tastes
you can have both
okay so you know what when people say
you have to choose one over the other
for kids don't discuss the burger can
taste nice and it could also be
delicious the burger can taste nice and
it can also be yeah there's one thing
you should take away from this the
burger can taste nice and also be
delicious so Matthew is clarifying that
he appreciates a toasted barn so what
I'm gonna do is toast
my fire whoo look at that all right I
have
aha burger here whoo and you lost I love
people fun glad to see those on there
for me I would love to have like ketchup
for mail on there and maybe some like
lettuce but you know what I think it can
still be great I do like the mustard in
the pickle go really great together you
have hundred feet from the mustard and
the pickle is both sweet and sour so
that's a really great contrast to your
meaty burger it a little bit overcooked
for my liking I can't prefer like a
juicier thicker burger but you have all
those classic diner flavors in there and
it really kind of reminds me of my
childhood
thank you solid effort thank you so much
and now Jessica I can definitely tell
you went for like a more elevated burger
versus like the classic diner I like to
use red onions on this I think that'll
be really great with the cheese on the
inside and play with the lamb what kind
of truth was in the center go cheese go
cheese that was gonna be good your
burger is cooked very differently than
augustine's I like the doneness of your
that's still juicy and tender but you
kind of have like almost none of the
char he has if you could like get this
done this but like let it kind of go at
a higher heat for longer so you look a
nice char that'd be really good and when
I did get a bite of the goat cheese it
was a great Tang eNOS compared
everything else we didn't toast your
bond at all so it's kind of just kind of
falling apart I think the onions and the
bacon taste great so this is not how I
thought this was gonna turn out but I'm
gonna have to say I'm gonna go with
Augustin he's the winner I like how the
strong mustard and pickles and onions
and with that burger thank you so much
yeah I'm very happy with how you did I
was not expecting it to be as good as it
was and it was really good I'm gonna
cook this again tonight and do exactly
what you told you you do perfect I love
that
[Music]